yourself guys my name is Samuel EADS I
wanted to introduce you to a guy called
James Armstrong I met James Armstrong
when he was and he was 19 or maybe just
turned 20 he took my property training
courses
he went into debt to go on my property
training courses my brain went into his
brain and then he took the knowledge ran
with it
he became financially free in his early
twenties starting with absolutely
nothing
he's now still killing it in property he
made 70,000 pounds of one deal sourcing
fee one time but he's doing deals began
again again again again this really is a
testament that anybody can do it even if
you're young even if you start with no
money he's been on winners Wednesday
before his coma
YouTube time before he's still doing
well even after all these years so here
he is James Armstrong enjoy how much
money are you now making through
property about 4,000 pound a month about
4,000 pound a month you've quit your job
yeah I quit that back in August that's
cool Congrats browser so cool what's
been your strategy so I wrote four deal
sourcing okay I mean with deal sourcing
you have to learn about all different
strategies anyway unless you just want
to source HMOs but I do bespoke sourcing
so it's a case of sitting down an
investor and finding out what's the best
investment for them so I've been through
all the different training so I know
about all the different types of
strategies and after doing that I
thought well deal sourcing is what I
want to do it sounds like the most fun
allows you to get started with no money
so I went and I did deal sourcing and
yeah from then I've done HMO single
let's rent to rents rent to essays by
refurbs now so kind of every strategy
but my strategy is deal sourcing I know
a lot of your investors are quite
wealthy they might not even a lot of you
investors don't even live in England no
they don't they're from Dubai yeah org
an eight-hour flight plus stoppages and
stuff together
how much will he make me policy now I
say I say deal sourcing is doing about
12 grand a month don't spit between LTI
and then you've got developments torn
out areas and when they finish they
members will supply about 35 grams
what's being the most impressive deal
that you've done back in March
yeah about three four weeks and have
control the last one over the Wednesday
I saw the portfolio 60 houses yeah my
father's feeling that was three percent
of purchase prices which was 60 65 grams
in one deal is that a new bank and I had
a call last week as well as making 16 K
from the head of global staffing at
Google that was that was a fun
conversation I phone call from Google
last week yeah he's putting a
million-pound is the UK property market
probably nearly 50 K around that not bad
the one from the crash course of the
nice 16 or some of them two winners on
the Wednesdays as well yeah yeah yeah
that's so good
so what's going on like with the
lockdown and stuff are you you fought
the accelerator and waiting to get back
to normal or you continue to work on
property a lot it has to work our
property man obviously I've got more
time naturally so I don't have to take
my foot off to get the time that I would
want to get by taking my fourth so I'm
still pushing on the deal sauce and on
the property that is that is very much
my main front why are we giving Louis
more time so just spent readings been
you know looking into new areas of new
deals etc etc looking at systemising the
business you know all that backend stuff
that sometimes just gets put to the back
of the queue in a normal life 9 to 5
good you don't have the time to do some
of the stuff that's it's less important
doesn't repay you but it helps
streamline things but more like some
those templates your emails and things
you're doing that is really really cool
and then you pushing more social media
pushing more YouTube videos things like
that and then outside of that look
in two different investment areas I
still want to stay on property but I
want to do more deals for myself and
things like that so I've actually looked
into into crypto recently and spoke them
into that but very much very much
property 100% property about a year ago
yes I do I remember it very very clearly
it's fine if you want to move away from
property but whatever you do under every
bite never ever ever forget property
never abandon property like equals these
are what you said never abandon property
you can come in and out you know I love
training at the moment then I'll come
back and do more property then I'll pop
this mails maybe but never take you for
out of property always do that because
sometimes it's easy and you're young
successful how are you it's all I
experienced that in a star of my journey
in the Academy because I started off
doing deal source doing I had a bit of a
rough patch when I message to you about
you know I can't seem to get any
investors and you know that that period
I started looking for more interest ace
and I took my father gasp and three most
looking for interest a he's got a few
then they fell through and then the
minute I'm about to deal saw saying you
know I made ten grand
three days later literally three days
later I said okay so this is what I need
to be doing this works and I just wasted
three months by laughing off into a
different strategy still property but
not focusing and I really found the
value then of focusing and you know if
use it's an acronym it's follow-on
course until successful doesn't mean you
can't another course later but just get
that one working and then you can branch
out so now deal source is going well you
know look three full-time members of
staff now I don't really have to know
awful lot in the business and I'm
beginning to systemize it take me out so
I can do more deals and where ya talk to
me about some of the I mean I really
like what you said about that you set up
systems and streamlining stuff only the
exact same in my business so that when
things do go back to normal I we can
leave our houses on their ever gonna
completely go back to the way that
there's going to be change in terms of
in terms of things go back to normal to
a point I think that if we can
streamline a systemized things that
actually work life is easier moving
forward yeah that's a really cool thing
so give me some examples of how you've
done that within your within your
business
sure well initially I said there's three
stages in the systemization one is just
earn more money so you're able to do
like pay for the things that you need to
do to get your time back once you saw
some once you've grown your business now
then let's outsource immediate tasks so
if you're doing your own bookkeeping get
a bookkeeper think simple things like
that anything what you're doing it
yourself or you could be outsourcing it
in some of your social media management
I still think you should do a lot of it
yourself but you know some of your
social media management things like that
you can outsource it and then after that
there are some tasks you just have to
pay people to do and get stuff so for me
I mean a bee-like was isn't is
incredible for just a lot of the
investor handling I once once I've sold
the deals not a lot I have to do I'm
glass pretty much down to how Abby
handles all the solicitors and brokers
and stuff which is very very helpful for
me and then I've just employed two
analyses a full-time deal sorcerer and
they will take over the sales role in
due course once they're at a point in
which they can do it but then that then
our finding deals regularly you know
they understand the deal sourcing side
then when I'm checking on that they're
right they can come up with their own
offers they can quote their own bill
cost like that know what they're doing
and then obviously the next stage for
them is they'll take over the sales days
and then the emails and so nice that we
pretty much me out of the business I
don't have to be there every single day
yes I run it yes I still but it'll still
be my business it'll still make money on
my face but my actual time involved with
the operational side of what's going on
move very very minute I can you can deal
sourcing is something that where I say
you can make a lot of money but it's not
passive but I guess if you employ people
and you systems it's a business anyway
and you can make anything passive yeah
it's a business at the end of the day
and I don't want to be self-employed
I want to have a business a business is
not a business until you can run it
without yourself but don't you be I'm
not gonna go spend six months away and
do nothing
I won't go do something crazy to make
that constructive but still I can choose
to it's very cryptocurrency because I
actually I actually do as a smart
to do especially right now because one
of my problems in challenges that I've
had is I've got so much money in
property and I was in the process of
selling some houses which and I have
sold quite a lot but but when this now
this has happened I don't really want to
sell right now I don't the matter all
right now so so you can have a lot of
money but if it's tied if it's tied up
in property it's not liquid at all and
having a money in the bank is not smart
so putting money in cryptocurrency I
think it's quite it's placed very liquid
I was you know I've got money in Bitcoin
I just sold some of my Bitcoin and I got
the money within a few hours so it's
very very liquid but at the same time
it's probably smiling having money in
the bank when they're printing so much
money right now I mean Granoff says that
cash is trash no don't think that's ever
been there's true statement that's right
now in 2000 yeah I mean you hit the nail
on the head there is worth knowing crypt
has obviously very volatile so one
morning you don't really know what's
gonna be worth for the next but when you
look at the amount of quantitative
easing that they're doing the u.s. just
flat-out stated they will do unlimited
quantitive easing and they haven't
actually recovered any of the deaths
that they bought back in 2008 last time
that they did it but you know and when
you look at that level that level of
quantitive easing if you can't expect
your your money to still be worth
something in the bank right all the
savings banks interest rates of water
fall off a cliff you know and the value
of money he's gonna become worth less
and less and less I really do think
inflation so so so systemization that's
really really cool what's happened to
you deal sourcing business during
lockdown because obviously it's very
challenging if you've been able to
suddenly deals we've been able to make
it yes I have we've probably made 25 odd
grand since the start of the lockout so
it's slower than normal I'm not gonna
lie to you it is slower my time on the
phone is more I get less messages in you
know it is very much slow we can't use
many houses I have less deals coming
through but it's not impossible to make
money as I always tell but like look yes
it's more difficult but it's not
impossible so quite frankly it doesn't
really matter there is no excuse to
still go out there and make money I know
that it's not easy I can see it but I'm
not gonna give in to that so we're still
selling deals I've noticed the ones
the biggest problem I have is people not
that people's trust in me or in my
business or even in the property market
or where it's going their trust is
within their own business a lot of
investors are people have got successful
businesses whether it be chiropractors
doctors or whatever you know then they
making good money in business they've
got some business profits 200,000
300,000 on the side and they want to
invest that in another form of income
they want to invest in property but when
their business has got people on
furloughs or not getting clients in you
know and they're losing a cause worth
the revenue you know they have to hold
their cash reserves because I'm after
about their own business because that is
their livelihood it's where they built
they're not yet in a position where it's
something is passive so they have to
ensure that that stays alive which means
I don't have the money right then to
invest so I'm noticing the bigger deals
people holding off on the things like
buying for every finance have been so
solid for me since July last year like
any any day of any week I could have
sold a body for every finance deal you
know your standard single that buy for
four we care whatever spent twenty on it
is worth ninety you know those ones they
still sell they still sell and that's
like a nine month solid and I mean week
in week out I could sell a deal like
that I'd have absolute confidence when I
put it on the list that I will get money
for it and multiple people messaging in
and then it's still true
so because you've prepared yourself by
building an investor list over the last
year so now now during this dry patch
for you you're able to kind of stay
afloat
yeah and I'm still getting new investor
leads and I'm I'm fat I'm getting more
investors now than before to some extent
the flow of deals are slower so we we
have huge numbers of houses that we
viewed over last year as you could
imagine
we've stole all those details when we
put offers in and they got rejected they
weren't on a list - a list that there is
a list 200 houses that we know have
already been stacked they've been viewed
I've got all the evidence of still there
all the videos hey all I gotta do is
make a phone calls the agency if I still
in the market and put our offer in I've
got a deal you know when you have that
many houses like it's gonna happen the
other thing that that we did was I don't
say I saw a cover I didn't see crowbars
coming no one did but I saw a lot down
coming about a week or so in advance and
I just stored up deals then
just I didn't send them all out in the
first week I was like you know let's
let's keep a few because I don't know
how long he's gonna go out I don't know
how he's used to me to find deals I
don't know what measures of cover their
place so I went into the start out with
like eight deals or something accepted
yeah and then and then went from there
it was it was it was weird then the
first week was like dry it's just like
dry and there was no sales nothing and
it was like the end of the week I was
like what's going on so I'm just I pick
him a photo I slide comb fall and
everybody in my phone I could remember
who had money I see whether a Stice
being people are something like right
where is my list I want to know where my
people are at I just start phoning
everybody and I spent one they've always
been
I know six seven hours in the phone by
nd vine him exactly where people were I
knew what they wanted I knew I needed to
do to make money and and missed two days
they at least on the first deal so that
they was slow for one that one one week
and then once an educated myself and
what was going on and where people were
so I think what would you do what do you
do when you run out of deals how are you
how are you filling the pipeline of
deals still got stuff reviewed and
having stacks so I got a lead I've had a
few leads come through for some larger
tentative blocks of flats and things
because people realizing the passive
income is going to come from them over
the course of the recession and for me
I've got about 15 of those I got sent
through from various developers over the
last few months I haven't really got
proper time to go down and do but now I
do so I've got other stuff I'm going to
be working on and see honest if I get
real stuck hell I'll just borrowed some
money from some people and then go buy
some houses for myself hmm and then it
doesn't matter if I don't make any money
in deal source it for two weeks or three
weeks I'll just deal sorting is one
strategy is there any other property
strategies that you're either doing or
looking to do this year that you're
excited about sure so I'm doing a bio
for every finance I spoke to you about
the house a while ago yeah that's the
middle of refurb that's to to be
finished any time the next few weeks
I've already got to find out which will
start the minute that that one's done
and that's all finance ready to goes
well into conveyancing I couldn't tell
you where it is but near completion and
then where
we've just exchanged contracts on our
biggest development today Anthony a
fantastic welcome it's it's a very big
property and he promised that I wouldn't
I promised that I wouldn't tell you yet
so big yesterday of the exchange of
contracts so I'm Antony because I did
I've been telling out and they don't
count your chickens until the hatch
never be easy until you've got the keys
know all these things so they're
predicting the properties of property
for by ten to twenty percent this year
which which sounds very realistic
I mean polytonic in 2020 year what let's
see that I don't see that because
everyone's there's gonna be a manhunt
for three months when people go back to
do more things I didn't have a chance to
do before they left
you know people gonna OH with now we can
certainly complete regard you can get
surveys and valuations booked in and
you're gonna get a false economy from
that it takes three months to buy a
house it takes three months which come
up on land registry you know it takes
ages to get things done so you talking
six months for any before you start to
see the better though the sellers are
being extremely stubborn I mean I'm
trying to go slow so is the moment
realize what's happening they'll have
some values six months ago a hundred
grand so I'm not prepared to go and
lower than a hundred branding saying it
but but that was six months ago and they
don't get it but no I mean ultimately I
think when you went I mean for me when
I'm buying I'm not buying two cups
appreciation I'm always buying for cash
grab yeah I was that if that happens if
the properties crash like crazy that
what's gonna happen to all you investors
that are buying those BR are our deals
though expectancy now to be financed in
six months I mean I'm then going to be
stuffed
that's a great question I personally
don't think so because I don't think
we're gonna see that drop until the
first quarter twenty twenty-one so I
don't think like if you can get out
before I would say if you can get out
before the end of October in your deal
ideally you should be fine if you get
out anything after that he playing a bit
of a risk but I think you'll be okay
so if you can get out before the end of
October I think you'll avoid the massive
drop and besides this continuously
billion a lot
anyway they'll still be great investment
houses easily five bragged about - it's
still gonna be a good deal for you
so I don't think we must have I'm not
massively concerned about that the other
thing that we're doing is properties
that are valued by rent and rents not
gonna go down so actually the asset
price isn't let me affected on those so
yeah great how do you get a sustained
value mean if probably crash all that's
gonna do is it's gonna create
opportunity and it's gonna mean that you
can get higher return on investment
because when I started out in property
in 2008 when there was a crash 2010-2011
properties were really low it's actually
it was actually great because you could
buy a house really cheap you can rent it
out for a reasonable went so if there's
a crash it probably just keep only men
are then it's only gonna be good for
those they've got in 20 years ago so
yeah I mean I have to look back and go I
wish I was around in 90s I could buy a
house for five grand I got five grand
now let's go buy a house but obviously
it's different it's different but yeah
like you say cheaper houses they're
gonna be great yeah yeah being fluid and
being able to adapt to strategy risk
assessing things buying knowing that the
property could drop it see if you'll see
for me it's interesting because I mean
I'm also doing development so buying
properties building properties selling
properties so I'm having to think you
know once again what's gonna happen
because I don't want to build a house
it's gonna take six twelve months to
build and then it's finished it's
actually not know what you want very
very interesting and it's great to get
you all your insight what would your
advice be to somebody watching this this
thinking about getting into property
it's a good time is here a bad time what
what or what it what's the strategy to
do because I think there's a lot of
people with a lot of questions right now
sure I think the strategy to do is
raising finance that's definitely got
easier and and it's the best way
building your own portfolio I think now
is probably if you genuinely know
nothing now it's probably the best time
to do it because it's gonna take you
time to learn what needs to get educated
learn how the strategies work but the
time you've learned that and you're
ready to go you know we'll be deep into
the recession the houses are only really
cheap you're gonna owe all of the
strategies to music at that time you
know you've already got the initial
feedback
he working with people and trainers and
in the network of people that know what
they're doing you know I'm go for it
right now and get educated right now
because you know it's gonna take you
time to learn I mean when you're then at
the point where you know what you're
doing and you can start to Reese or get
some contraction success in the market
you're gonna be at a point where there's
just so much opportunity around and all
the people are amateur and don't know
what they're doing when people are
worried strategy heavily is lease option
agreement yeah because finding one today
I do over seven years though well longer
the better but the great game at lease
option agreement is you have your cake
and eat it too because at the end of the
term if it's five seven ten years if it
has dropped then you just say well
thanks for the cash flow or not now and
if it's dipped it might dip over the
next 12 12 months or so and then it
could rock it that often doesn't happen
after a recession acclaimed bounce-back
rebound today with that happens five
seven ten years and it's amazing because
I can remember in 2008 when everyone was
saying you know property markets doomed
people honestly believe that powers as
people telling me all they're gonna
they're gonna go back to like they were
like in the 50s they're gonna be worth
five grand that's what people were
genuinely believed and they were
genuinely saying and actually what
happened is they went down dropped about
twenty three percent depending on where
you were and then rocketed to three is
later so it's very very interesting but
no I really appreciate you your advising
you in but is there any way that I can
support you or help you in what you're
doing right now if you gotta spread
deals man send them through you're
looking for deals either to do myself or
to sell yeah I want to do some more
deals myself but mainly so if you've got
anything of any interest or you know
anyone who's got deals then want a shift
to do some it put them in touch for me
and I want it dude thanks so much for
your time and anytime man drop me mister
whatsoever anytime shall do bro looking
forward to seeing you soon he's not my
friend
[Music]